Antonia was with us in a little rock hey
Antonio Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
hey how are you better than I deserve
what's up I'm calling today because I
just I'm happy some advice and some
guidance of my wife um she's kind of
gotten out of control with their
spending I've been following you for a
while
about a year now and I've been trying to
get her on board with doing this but it
just hasn't worked and now I mean he's
at a point where it's just out of
control and I'm you know I'm just kind
of terrified for my family we have a
four year old so I just kind of need
some help
mm so what kind of stuff is she spending
money on this the thing that you're like
I really don't know what she has a
credit card
she got a credit card this year and she
maxed it out at $6,000 what she bombs he
has hello yes sir what did she buy uh I
mean I couldn't really tell you what she
bought about $6,000 worth of stuff and
you don't have any idea what it is I
mean I go home every day and I look
around and I don't see anything besides
clothes I guess I mean maybe clothes I
would say but nothing really there's
worth anything so and she also has
$120,000 worth of still on there and she
also has a car loan that she just got
which I told her that we need to sell
the car because we're broke so and I
don't she doesn't want to sell the car
but I I know we need to sell the car
mm-hmm
so she wouldn't bought a car without you
shining yes sir so I'm not like on the
car loan or anything like that what does
she do for a living
she's a social worker so she works for
the state of Arkansas making
what kind of money she makes about
$36,000 a year then $20,000 in debt to
do that what do you make I make about
29,000 a years mm-hmm
and how long have you guys been married
we've been married for four years we've
been together for five years
so where you're 28 now I'm 24 she's 26
okay so you got married back when she
was in school and you were in school
then yes sir
well she had just I think she had just
finished up her bachelor's degree or
something like this and that she has a
master's degree as well so something
like that yes okay well I mean you guys
are or the Sheila on this car he just
got the car so I mean $31,000 this she
owes and I told her that the best thing
for it would be to sell the car
so because we can't afford it I mean
mm-hmm
and I don't I mean I don't have any dish
I don't have any money but I also don't
have any days so I just I've been just
trying to get her to get on board with
with me and you know you just hasn't
worked
yeah okay well yeah she's got a real
financial problem I mean and and since
you're married to her you have a real
financial problem I met her in the
$150,000 in debt with a 50 or $60,000
household income and you know that car
you're right it's insanity it has to go
but and another 6,000 and credit cards
and but the problem is is that we don't
have any admission that there's a
problem she doesn't think it's a problem
I don't know most of the time when I try
to talk to her about paying off the debt
and still holidays she'll tell me
there's no way we can pay off this day
you know it's just not gonna happen you
know I don't know you know she was like
something like today you know experience
when I usually bring up something about
paying off to do something like this
well it's gonna take a while yeah
well it's a it is a depo and basically
what we're saying is it might be that
she's less of a princess and more
hopeless and hopeless sounds like we're
gonna be in debt forever anyway I might
as well have a good car
you know that's hopeless that's not like
slamming your fist on the table and
going well I deserve like a little
spoiled kid or something I deserve a
nice car that I'm gonna get whatever I
want I'm gonna go buy stuff and break
out any time I want it might be that she
just thinks you guys are stuck and
you're never gonna get out and she's she
feels like you know you have a death
sentence of financial death sentence
that you're a life sentence in prison
you know you're gonna be there forever
and and what we've got to do is try to
give her some hope probably let me ask
you this if if you sat down with her and
said I am worried about our relationship
and I'm worried about our future because
I am NOT okay and I'm but getting
progressively angry at your behavior
with money I'm not okay calmly not
yelling and fussing and screaming but
I'm getting very very very frustrated
and angry with the continued spending
and the problems and the fact that we're
not on the same page and I don't think
this is going to end well for us if we
don't get some help and so we needs we
need some help and and then you know if
you sat down and said I want us to go to
Financial Peace University this
nine-week class if I give it to you can
you get her to go with you oh yes I
would be to go with you sure you can't
get her to do anything else I mean we're
kind of basically what you just
described it's kind of reached a point
where listen we have to get on the same
page because you're not just is it's
affecting both of us you know that
out-of-control spending so and our son
so it's affecting that all of us yeah
[Music]
with a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in debt and no husband is where
it's going to leave her eventually and
she doesn't need that I want to help her
make the render I really know I
what I want you to do I want you to be
all-in and she gets anything and
everything you have you're married it's
combined it's not it's not like it's a
friend that you're helping this is your
wife you do it you know in sickness and
in health for richer for poorer but you
guys got to get on the same page and
then but once she's on the same page
with you and you're both sacrificing you
can do anything then and you should do
anything work extra go crazy and clean
up the mess sell the car got the credit
card and let's work extra and go crazy
and clean up the mess hold on I'll have
Kelly pick up we'll get you signed up
for Financial Peace University as our
Christmas gift hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]